- So you're in the new
live action "Cinderella"
which I am so excited to see.
And you play a version
of the Fairy Godmother.
Will you tell us more about that?
- Yeah, you know.
They called and they asked me
to play the Fairy Godmuvva,
as I call
him/her/they/them/she/it, whatever.
And you know, all I could think was that,
"You're asking me to play
the Whitney Houston part?"
- I love that you know
that version. (laughing)
And Brandi.
- Wait, you're asking me
to play the Whitney Houston part?
♪ Impossible ♪
Like I was like, (screaming).
Yes, of course!
What I love about it though,
what I love about the position
is that it really speaks to my brand,
for lack of a better word,
which is about challenging
gender norms and stereotypes.
What does it mean to be a man?
What is masculinity exactly?
And why do we, in this culture,
think that masculine is
better than feminine?
I say, when I was trying to live up
to the expectations of others,
I was broke and bankrupt and jobless.
When I chose myself, here we are.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I agree.